hablamos de salud en este día directo
america marc bienvenida feliz mañana
vamos a hablar entonces del gobierno de
reino unido que publicó los posibles
escenarios de desarrollo de la pandemia
y kobe 19 son escenarios positivos o
negativos que podemos esperar de este
informe más un poco de todo no sé si
eres de los que te gusta saber las malas
noticias que te esperan en el fusil yo
prefiero darlas para estar ya preparado
y saber cómo comportarme bueno entonces
a escucha atentamente porque este
informe del gobierno de eeuu de los
expertos de crisis sanitaria del
gobierno han hecho unas previsiones que
tratan de ir desde el mejor escenario
posible dentro de lo razonable hasta el
peor según estas previsiones el mejor
escenario es uno en el que el virus del
cómic 19 se mantiene con unas
características parecidas a las que
conocemos por lo tanto igual de
transmisible e igual de grave más o
menos pero que con la vacunación en la
inmunidad que tenemos por los contagios
pues la gravedad relativa disminuye esto
es más o menos lo que se prevé pero el
kobe no desaparece la pandemia no para y
siguen habiendo unos ciclos de
enfermedad sobre todo relacionados pues
con el invierno y las bajas temperaturas
en el escenario llaman central optimista
es decir oscilando hacia lo positivo ven
que hay unos ciclos parecidos como los
que estamos viviendo ahora con omicron
es decir que hay unos años buenos unos
años malos y en los años malos tocar
recuperar algunas restricciones de
distanciamiento social para evitar pues
que la enfermedad se extienda más allá
de los grupos que no son vulnerables del
lado poco a poco vamos pasando al
escenario más pesimista hablamos de que
hay nuevas variantes que emergen como ya
hemos visto que ha sucedido pero que
sigue pasando a lo largo de los años el
virus es más transmisible se escapa más
fácilmente a nuestra inmunidad y la
pandemia sigue impactando gravemente a
la vida normal y la vacunación además
tiene que mantenerse cada año para toda
la población en el peor escenario
posible previsto por este grupo de
expertos todavía dentro de lo que
consideran razonable es que la vacuna no
llega a todo el mundo por lo tanto las
variantes de emergen cada vez más
virulentas la pandemia se hace algo
bastante impredecible y las medidas de
protección como las mascarillas del
distanciamiento social de nuevo están
discutidas socialmente es decir no son
de consenso
en términos de vacunación y de consenso
social no sé qué piensas tú raúl pero me
parece que estamos peligrosamente cerca
de este peor escenario sin lugar a dudas
para llegar a este mejor escenario
tenemos que tener algo de suerte pero
también tenemos que vacunar a todo el
mundo por supuesto equidad en la
vacunación es que es un problema global
y si no entendemos eso pues no estamos
haciendo nada para eliminar de nuestro
mundo de nuestra vida el kobe 19 dejamos
el cohete en la domar hablemos de una
enfermedad que cobra muchas vidas pero
con una buena noticia para los pacientes
de cáncer de mama un fármaco muestra que
puede impedir la metástasis marc así es
es una buena noticia no todo no todo es
malo es una investigación desarrollada
en barcelona por el hospital vall
d'hebron es un fármaco que se llama homo
mic y que se usaba contra tumores
primarios pero que ahora se ha visto que
puede incluso hacer que la metástasis
remita que desaparezca el equipo de
investigación lo explicaba así en un
comunicado
y así pudimos ver que en ratones
modificados genéticamente como mick era
capaz de hacer que el tumor primario
creciera menos pero también observamos
que impactaba en el crecimiento de la
metástasis y en algunos casos las hacía
desaparecer cuando administramos como
mick por vía intravenosa los resultados
también fueron positivos ya que vimos
que se producía una disminución del
crecimiento del tumor y que se alargaba
significativamente la supervivencia de
los ratones este fármaco lo que hace es
inhibir una proteína que se ha visto que
tiene un rol protagónico en el
desarrollo de la metástasis de los
tumores pero es muy importante destacar
que este fármaco y este estudio solo
todavía se ha realizado en ratones y en
cultivos todavía no en personas está en
estudio en fase 1 es decir que se está
comprobando si es seguro para usar en
humanos entonces toca esperar a ver cómo
se sigue desarrollando pero si estos
estudios progresan y realmente es seguro
y efectivo en las personas pues será un
avance clave porque impedir la
metástasis es una cosa que es
imprescindible para asegurar la
supervivencia de los pacientes una vez
desarrollan cáncer usted más hablaba de
seguridad
el próximo tema es un tema de la
redundancia de seguridad para las
mujeres y también de salud pública
colombia despenalizó el aborto hasta las
24 semanas de gestación pues sí es un
anuncio que venimos dando desde ayer por
la tarde pero ahora vamos a hablar de
las implicaciones que tiene esto para la
salud de las mujeres y de las personas
que este antes ayer un equipo de france
24 estaba en la celebración en bogotá de
la capital colombiana y recogieron estas
declaraciones a partir de hoy mismo toda
mujer niña adolescente en colombia no
tenga que correr el riesgo de tener un
aborto inseguro sino que pueda ir al
sistema de salud a hasta la semana 24 de
gestación y luego por las causales que
son derechos fundamental hace 15 años
esto va a permitir salvar muchísimas
vidas esperamos que nunca más se repita
las muertes por abortos inseguros como
la que le ocurrió a lorena félix en
barranquilla hace tan solo un mes y
medio
mencionaba en este caso de lorena una
mujer que murió por una hemorragia
debido a un aborto clandestino pero es
que no es un caso aislado se calcula que
son 70 alan más o menos aproximadamente
las mujeres que mueren cada año en
colombia debido a estos abortos
clandestinos
130.000 sufren complicaciones en su
salud a raíz también de realizar abortos
en lugares que no son seguros se calcula
que aproximadamente el 90% de las
interrupciones de embarazo en el país
son en estos ambientes no seguros
entonces recordar que todos los en las
interrupciones del embarazo raúl se
deben dar en ambientes controlados con
supervisión médica y garantizando los
derechos de las mujeres y seguimos
hablando de este tema marc esto con
nuestra segunda invitada del día gracias
por toda la información de salud
ampliamos este tema del aborto con esta
segunda mitad